she is just weeks old but has already
undertaken a journey few will ever
comprehend how old is this baby 40 days
at sea for nine hours before being
rescued by the rnli her life now quite
literally in the hands of the home
office
her name is ayan born at some point
during her parents journey from iraq on
arriving at dungeness she hadn't been
fed for two hours prompting concern
among police and border force officials
but for her exhausted mother there's
just sheer relief
the worst is now over why did you risk
her life to come across the channel
the dangers they face are put into sharp
relief when you see the boat they
traveled in barely big enough for ten it
carried four times that
a window of karma weather has seen
crossings increase with french
authorities also seeming to have played
a part on friday sky news witnessed
migrants leaving france in the full gaze
of police there who did nothing to stop
them it appears to have been no
different this time around
did they did you see french police no
don't say anything because the police
is not like dangerous man from the other
country
he don't say he respect me
he said just just wait if you can't you
wait now big bot come they think you'll
do that it's a good life i say thank you
very much
so the police the police did not try and
stop you in france from leaving in the
boat no
for one migrant the risk-taking wasn't
over
attempting to make a break for it across
the shingle and into the marshes beyond
he didn't get far brought back in
handcuffs five minutes later
from here the migrants will be taken to
dover where they'll be processed none of
them can know what lies ahead of that
but they're all certain it's better than
what they've left behind
as if to underline the point as one
group left another arrived around 70 in
the space of three hours
when some are willing to risk everything
to reach these shores the crossings will
be very difficult to stop
iva bennett sky news dungeness